imagine if you could light a light bulb
with a pencil today I'd like to share
with you a material that's inside of a
pencil that can do just that I'm talking
about graphene hi my name is Aneesa
Ramirez welcome to my lab at Yale
University I'd like to share with you a
Nobel prize-winning material that's
found in a pencil that's gonna
revolutionize our lives but first what
makes up a pencil well there's the
eraser there's the wood the part that
I'm talking about is the part that
you're right with which is graphite now
many people think it's made out of lead
but it's not lead at all it's all carbon
now carbon is an old friend you and I
are made out of carbon carbon comes in
many different forms or allotropes each
with different properties there's
diamond which is one of the hardest
materials that we know and there's
graphite which is one of the softest
both are made out of carbon the
difference is the way that carbon atoms
bond in each one of these materials in
diamond carbon atoms bond like this each
carbon has four very strong bonds in
graphite carbon atoms bond like this
each atom has three very strong bonds
within a layer and then a weak bond
between layers here lies a secret for
that material that's going to help
revolutionize our world but first let's
talk about a few other forms of carbon
few years ago scientists found balls of
carbon or buckyballs they also found
tubes of carbon or nanotubes the ways
that carbon bonds seems exhausting but
there's one more and that's graphene
which looks like this now in order to
understand graphene we have to go back
to our old friend graphite graphene is
one layer of graphite it's one atom
thick now how do you make graphene what
we can do is we can break this bond here
and we do that in pencils all the time
when we write with a pencil we break
this very weak bond and leave layers of
carbon well the Nobel laureates that
found graphene did just that
only they got a piece of graphite and
they applied a piece of tape to it and
they did this numerous times until they
got to a very thin
piece of eventually graphene and then
they tested the electrical properties of
the graphene and they found that
electricity passes through the graphene
really fast much faster than regular
graphite it's the one layer of atoms
that allow electrons to move for this
material super super fast super fast
electrons means super fast computers
let's look at carbon in action here I
have a circuit where we're able to light
up a light by using graphite just from a
regular mechanical pencil let's try this
together Wow
that's pretty neat let's try something
else let's just draw a line with the
pencil and see if we can get the light
bulb to light too let's try it again
that's pretty cool and scientists think
that graphene is pretty cool too because
electricity moves through it so quickly
we'll be able to make computers with it
that are very fast computers will be a
hundred times faster scientists are also
interested in graphene because it's
super strong if you were to have an
elephant balanced on a pencil you would
not be able to break a layer of graphene
that's the thickness of saran wrap
that's really strong that's going to
change the way we make everything so you
see the material that's at the tip of a
pencil is about to revolutionize our
lives we're at a tipping point our old
friend carbon has a few new tricks up
its sleeve and will change our lives in
ways that we can't even predict I'm
Anissa Ramirez thank you for joining me
in my lab at Yale University and I hope
that you'll join us for another material
marble